[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis us
chefs champs comm presents the third
annual winter chest classic hello and
welcome back to our live coverage of the
2019 winter chess classic we're in the
home stretch here sabina as this is
round eight today with just one round
left to go after today of course we are
your hosts my name is caleb debbie this
is the wonderful sabina foyer and we
will be giving you the play-by-play
coverage today over these chess games
and what a tournament it's been so far I
still cannot believe we're about to
close it up with one more round tomorrow
and of course today's round which is
very exciting yes the players are trying
to make sure they get some extra points
get to the top yeah there's there's no
time left to dois tell these players of
course maybe earlier on in the
tournament they had some time if they
wanted a break they could maybe make an
easy draw with white but now it's now or
never yeah either you win these games
and come home with that first-place
prize or or you go home a loser I
wouldn't say that it's kind of harsh I
mean it's just you know you have a bad
tournament so you certainly have to come
back from me it's you you take your
lessons and you move on of course I mean
but it's certainly for this one you know
you're not really doing so great but
it's okay you know it's it's chess and
very good chess player you learned that
of course these wonderful parents here
in st. Louis everybody goes home with
with some prize money
these Invitational tournaments great
opportunities for these players for sure
test their mettle of course and they
have some chances to play some other
strong players and then get a prize as
well so very beautiful conditions here
at the sandwiches Club I really enjoy
coming here every time I might be biased
but I also like it here yeah well why
don't we see where we stand after these
first seven rounds Rinat Jim abayas is
man in the a group he has five points
out of seven and actually looking at his
games he has never been worse he's
played amazingly consistent amazingly
accurate chess and that puts him at the
top of the leaderboard Geoffrey Zhang as
well has also been playing incredibly
well in fact the only man able to take
down Geoffrey Zhang has been Reena Juma
buyeth so it'll be interesting to see if
Geoffrey can make up that point
difference even though he lost in the
head-to-head matchup against Rinat
Daniel married its key in Sam seven are
the other two players in this a group
but are still able to catch the leader
so with some good fortune and some good
chess they might also make it up to that
number one position
sure Sethu has actually had the turn
around tournament uh but I guess the the
Cinderella story
yeah of the tournament he started off
actually with three losses yes since
then he has scored three and a half
points out of his last balance that was
quite impressive although yesterday we
weren't quite sure about he's really
early draw but he didn't have the black
pieces so in a way you know yes just
glorious draw with black oh yeah your
Gauri Oprah is also on three and a half
points and that leaves Viktor Erdos
Alexis Serena Ivana's caboose Ian and
vara Cobian to round out the a group the
B group is a totally different story
with these standings there are actually
four players tied for the lead in this B
group so these last two rounds will
decide at all
Melik ah-chan also cannot be counted out
just a half point behind these four
leaders definitely within striking
distance getting that first place or at
least forcing a playoff he had some a
great tournament he's been coaching a
lot lately and he said this is kind of
tournament where he's coming out of
retirement but yeah he's been doing
pretty great I think he hasn't played in
a long time that's no I believe actually
Christopher you mentioned in his
interview
Melek has been his coach as of late so
it's a little interesting story there
with with both teacher and student can
we complete each other in the tournament
yeah
- grandpa routine is on three and a half
out of seven else Shawn
Justin Wang and surrogate Ehrenberg all
on two and a half and Christopher you on
two points in this B group and why don't
we actually take a quick look at the
tournament format as well see what kind
of format these players are playing in
there are of course two ten player round
robins that is the a group and the B
group that we just looked at the time
control for the event is 90 minutes for
40 moves and then 30 minutes is added on
for the remainder of the game
there is a 30-second increment for move
one and in addition to these rules
there's also a draw rule in effect no
draw offers are allowed before blacks
thirtieth move so the game will continue
past move 30 barring any three move
repetition or by some miracle stalemate
yes it's kind of hard but we're sure we
have seen some very impressive just here
at the winter just classic so that role
has its yeah it has made its goal I
think well yeah yeah I don't know if
it's down to the draw rule or it's just
down to these blues players playing some
really interesting chess but either way
it's been an exciting tournament to
watch for sure and they're playing for
some great prizes so I think you know no
you know even maybe not having that rule
over there they would still be trying to
fight for for the top prizes so yeah and
I do want to mention that today is round
eight that means tomorrow is the final
round of this winter chess classic of
course that means the round actually
starts two hours early as will our show
so of course we've been starting up
around 3:30 p.m. every day but tomorrow
be sure to join us live at 1:30 p.m. for
our live coverage of these players
amazing
means also I do want to mention you even
talked about prize funds maybe we can
pull up that graphic as well
these players playing for a total prize
fund of $22,000 in the a group with
first place prize taking home a very
significant $6,000 chunk of that and in
the B group it's nothing to laugh at
either it's fourteen thousand dollars at
stake with first place taking home four
thousand dollars so a lot at stake here
in the B group for sure and I I mean I'm
sure we're going to see some very some
decisive games in these last two rounds
because you know everyone is trying to
improve their place in the standings
yeah and trying to get a little bit you
know a little bit of a higher price get
that heyday of course always chess
players care very much about that rating
as well that's what gets them more
invitations to more tournaments that's
what you know it's a good marker of
their progress in their chests curious
or sure always something to play for
even if you're relegated to the lowest
prizes but I do as always want to thank
you guys for joining us here on YouTube
see Patrick Daly joining us once again
McHale tall isn't in the chat room
interesting operation chest ninth
Coronel white thank you all Marcus W
thank you for joining us as always if
you want to get involved on Twitter you
can do so using the hashtag winter chess
classic and if you want to follow the
games for yourself be sure to head on
over to us chess champs calm where you
can see all of the games live with some
engine analysis and check out those
games that you find most interesting
well Sabina I believe we actually
already have some interesting results I
don't know if we can't actually start
with the B group pairings and maybe see
what's going on there let's do that we
have Sergey Ehrenburg against Tigran
virginian melech Koch Ian against
federico perez poncy sergey Arenberg
against emilio cordova and then our
result has come in in the B group for
this next game l Shawn Marathi Abadi has
defeated one of the group e leaders
Alexey Sorokin
and a very interesting game with a
devastating attack on the Kings side and
I believe in just a few moments we're
actually going to try to get el Shawn in
here and our key matchup of the day is
actually Sergey Azeroth against
Christopher you Sergey of course one of
those tournament leaders plenty against
the lowest rated player and and actually
the the bottom on the leaderboard right
now Christopher you trying to make a
full point to it to extend that lead and
we see the players there and Sabina
maybe I can leave it to you to introduce
what's going on in this game and I will
step out of my chair
well we get a L Shaun and to talk about
his his amazing wins sounds good I am
looking forward to getting to talk about
that game I I wasn't able to watch it
from the beginning as I had some other
assignments but I'm really looking
forward to discussing that and
intervening action there should be
something really cool so for today for
this game right Sergei Azhar of against
Christopher you Wow
what didn't what some interesting
positions so black does have in this
position an extra pawn but White's just
playing Knight to f4 threatening some
very annoying you know attacks putting
some pressure on the Kings side so I
think I think black has has to be
careful and how to try to defend this
position but we are here with
Grandmaster L Charles Nelson where are
you buddy
what's a great game from garage nice
beautiful game I haven't had the chance
to finally you'll have an interview i
okay yeah it's kind of interesting to
have you here we've never been in this
position me having to interview you live
it's happening so a with a very
beautiful game tell me tell me about
your mood going in today's game you had
a very tough loss and kind of a tough
tournament here the winter just classic
I think you had other hopes for this
tournament what do you think went wrong
for yourself so far in the tournament
playing I was just playing poorly with
black like pieces yeah our game - it was
completely that played a very bad
opening didn't play game the other two
games I had to make a draw but blundered
in one more so yeah
but we both I played reasonably fine I
mean game grounds three against Melek I
had advantage close to winning mm-hmm
okay and in Game one and Game five
against second I remember - okay
against whatever point in one moment I
had to go 95 and again sponsor I had
very good very good very good position
so I played with somebody well just
instrument with white and I feel bad I
mean I don't know him Alex Lee but he
goes to Texas Tech so I'm sure he will
become a Grandmaster one day very soon
and he's a good coach and good teammates
so he will become a grandmaster very
sorry he still has a chance to make make
a norm yesterday we interviewed him and
he mentioned that he needs one out of
two to score his norm do you think that
could have been pressure on him to
respond psychological points yes he said
he had to nars and he was going to go
for his third norm at third norm in this
tournament thing he needed 102 - he was
pretty happy with his draw yesterday and
today you played in this tournament a
lot of e4 and for today you decided to
go for c4 yeah I think he didn't expect
that because in a database the last game
I have see forest back to 2014 so would
you mind speaking up a little bit make
sure that okay so
no no just rights not no okay this line
please
this is pretty this is pretty Tara -
yeah yeah I mean yeah right yeah III and
then after he five this mystery I think
the water played against Korra wanna and
feel Carwin or something like that yeah
Alex Thunderman pointed out to me this
idea and I analyze this for the US team
in Kazakhstan mm-hmm disposition so by
the way option for those of you who are
watching he was the captain of us no I
mean the coach of the US men's team in
the World Chess Championship earlier
this year and you were you're helping
some of the players players so this I
think it's five we should be seven is
the best idea but let's see what he
played is reasonable deal to try to go
for someone to forage for something like
that I think there's a game of no water
plating a chick League against some
polish player and nvl against Caruana I
extensively went over it looks very
benign but it's not exactly so you don't
have a lot of analysis there to play
there are a few things I mean but Bishop
e7 seems like a natural you know one
thing is he cannot watch five anymore
because if he goes h5 I'll go a four if
he goes h4 I go at five I lock it and
then the night sits on e4 and Bishop on
e3 and this is a very to blockade not HF
to and the edge file becomes universe so
do you bring this Knight to e4 and then
Bishop e5 means I have to also go G for
years - yeah G 90g 494 and Bishop e3 a
very solid blockade and the bishop and
see it is not in the game right now yet
the entire time I think but like we
might be able to really take it because
there's anything I come into play all
right so 496 so yeah it's a fine for
since seems very beautiful to try to get
maybe your knight into play she was
going to catch actually I was going for
drive I took the chip on but I think we
the knight is possible but my plan is to
play take and play a five and a four yes
the final position merely expected you
should take such three actually
okay because then later on maybe he can
okay I have to push-ups he can castle
and my attack doesn't going but he can
block it on dark squares so some money
to go bishops you to backing each one we
should be three bishops you want mm-hmm
Oh beautiful idea trying to to put your
bishops kind of in the other side of
blacks King but just focusing on because
if five idea goes with neither for
coming to d5 but without tonight I don't
think I have a but I think he has enough
time to equalize yeah so your night was
kind of helpful for him not having been
able to take your night now I was very
happy when you castle another move was a
five I was thinking maybe he would call
if I but I will call you for mmm-hmm and
then Bishop III 9f2 and that's the kind
of position I want to get the center so
much like it's sort of a King's Indian
position and I knew I knew that he's
kind of trying to play solid because he
didn't go for his main line which is
usually plays felt so he's trying so I
thought that I guess the fighting
position I was playing fast so I was
just getting it's a psychological you
you weren't ready because you know you
probably thought he's going to try to go
for two draws in these next two rounds
so yeah I mean next time he is white so
there's a very good chance so yeah so
this and then I was also surprised after
that this move can even go back please I
another interesting move here is g6
which is very counterintuitive because
if he goes Bishop h6 this is a bad move
should be six then Bishop takes a five
you give up exchange and then all the
dark scores are weak mm-hm
would he take with the Queen oh sure I
wasn't going for this I was about to
play a four but then I thought he can't
go Bishop f6 Bishop g7 trying to hold it
seems that you really understand it in
my attack it's it's nothing I think I
don't know what's the evaluation here
but I was very happy after 94 I felt
very confident that I have advantage
well you have a very good chain of pawns
over here with pointing towards the king
side and black is not really developed
yet so yeah defense right there's no
Knight yeah there's no 19 f6 cars over
there obviously I have the problem with
d3 but I always can't go not have to
defend it and I always have the G file
and the Queen goes to h5 so I was I was
pretty happy out of the opening I don't
know what
computer revolution is but I thought
what I wanted which was a know pretty
position I I really didn't think b5 was
very good for black it seems like he's
trying to get someplace we tried to
avoid engines here Elgin trying to make
basic not basic but as human I thought
he must go Bishop d6 67 I thought but
I'm not sure if my movies good after b5
Bishop f4 why not actually it's not bad
but I mean this is a very beautiful idea
you actually give up the pair of bishops
and you give the bishop that seemed to
do the good bishop in order to get a
beautiful night on the outpost an
initiative that that plays on so nobody
has to go Bishop e7 he simply blundered
here I think he missed 9f2
can we go further so it should be seven
you think here to try to control D
thought I was planning to just play slow
but I mean I have always night if to
King Gershwin and
yeah just slowly Queens 594 I mean I
think it's what's advantage black is not
really ready to take a control over the
DC this really far is not really a big
deal I can't even go to see one before
91 92 94 oh so he went before and now I
miss this I think this I think he missed
nine f2 here night-night goes to g4 and
here actually I think the best try
practical travel practice for the rock
d8 mmm-hmm I was a Philip this and I
haven't decided what to do but Knight g4
route 65 I give up the Queen and pretty
blockade uh-huh yeah I remember I
remember this kind of ideas myself when
I played the news championship last
round the one that I actually won I was
always worried that my opponent could
sacrifice the Queen and create the
blockade but yeah this this could be
kind of kind of annoying indeed but
after 96 you know you use very
completely destroying destroying the
area he missed because now we can show a
very beautiful lot first of all Queen d4
doesn't work because after Queen 64 64
is forced look a c1 and after Bishop e7
just yeah this is this is three pieces
were look
his game over and so 64 and cd4 can you
do the same I can
well I can't play Roxy Roxy one by the
queen is there I first have to kick the
Queen I was going to play with 93
actually or 94 but let's just start with
94 actually mm-hmm okay nice okay well I
mean if you watch double check
everything of course yet
I mean Queen b6 I could be 5 mm-hmm
because if it takes takes rook e1 and
then I take the bishop yeah and if he
goes can I go back please
and if it goes Queen b8 I again have the
move Knight rook c-13 is nicer because
then later I have a blockade too sure
but but 19 g4 you always have ideas a
night of 696 sacrificing the night and
mating so he went for Queen b8 and then
you know you're just I think you you did
choose the best the best possible moves
an e5 was very nice we were everything
this is a moment that I actually saw the
the position I 35 for yeah b5 I think he
must his only defense is Queen e8 when
there's a nice line here I goodnight 67
no 937 you cannot think we didn't Queen
takes we should have d5 check King gets
a truck f3 and I am sorting to take 107
I made g6 F takes G 699 text e4 e takes
f6 Knight x f3 check it sure takes f3
they're very beautiful win thanks for
joining us today
I'm so happy to have you here really
nice yeah you know it's it's nice to
come back sometimes I know you're yeah
sometimes you're not so confident
than yourself no I wasn't really
confident if you had gone for the Queen
sacrifice I'm sure I'm sure you were the
phone some way somebody obviously wasn't
good hit misty for that's why I went
back knight c6 and he missed 9 f2 so I
think it was psychological pressure
alright I mean I'm sure you'll become a
GM so maybe tomorrow we'll find it out
well thanks for joining us sell shares
great having you here we're gonna go
back to analyze some of the other very
cool very cool games very interesting in
in Group B and in Group A yeah for sure
yeah well we'll be sure to check on
those games thanks for joining us and
we'll see you
maybe tomorrow try and try your best
tomorrow wish you good luck for the last
run as caleb is coming back to join me
here let us let us go back to our game
of the day well game of our pickup the
day sarah has our of against Christopher
you and then we'll have to go back to
the a group as well since we kind of
went for the beautiful result early on
today Caleb just this is back in studio
yes indeed good to be back in the share
very nice interview for an all Sean I
wanted to mention he's a very gracious
winner yeah you don't hear many chess
players apologizing to their opponent
for ruining their norm change it's like
oh yeah I killed the guy I checked 96
and you know d4 and I'm the best but no
of course all Sean very very
professional and what wants to see his
his peers do you do well yeah and also
you know Al Shean did go to Texas Tech
University and now his opponent is going
there
so of course you know and you still want
the people who go to the same university
as you did of course to do well but this
is this is a game that should have a
winner and you cannot get yourself
influenced by any external factors you
have to try to just of course play the
game and and I wouldn't count alexei
circa now just yet
very good chances for him to still norm
just one went away and you know some
some players of course struggle with
with that kind of pressure but I think a
lot of chess players start thriving when
they you know under more pressure this
it's they somehow play worse when they
knew no they just have to draw them and
when they know they have to win yeah
somehow that it's kind of relieving to
just say all right I gotta go win yeah I
need to subtract to go yeah and also
tomorrow I believe Alex Oriakhi is going
to have the white pieces so yes should
be should be an interesting I'm not sure
who he's actually paired against but it
should have the white pieces tomorrow
yes you should have the white pieces and
try his best you know to win the last
round and get he's he's finding a miller
bit so what we talk about what's going
on in this key matchup in Group B
between Sergey Asura of it and
Christopher you I think you introduced
the game a bit but yeah I did not
realize that the Queen's are going to be
treated as L Shawn was getting set up
for the game we had this position where
y just had just played Knight to f4
putting pressure on e6 and I thought
white would have some interesting
attacking ideas but a few months later
the Queen's are of the board and
interesting to note Knight f4 makes more
than one threat there's all these things
like nineteen six in the years yeah
ignite age five threatening to take that
bishop sacrificing yeah and so it's not
it's not really super easy in this
position for for for black but Queen f7
seemed to have been the only move and
knowing stuff I wonder if there was
something else that white could have
done in this position to try to I don't
know just put keep more pressure I'm not
sure if Queen Queen trades I mean of
course Queen trades does make sense
because you do have this f1 idea
afterwards getting this night away a lot
of people when they're trying to attack
they think oh well I need the Queen on
the board so I have mating threats but
sometimes Queens are better defenders
than attackers yeah and that seems like
the case here with the black king queen
is covering f7 it covers g6 indirectly
covers h7 and g7 hmm
and by getting rid of that queen maybe
some of these weaknesses actually become
easier to attack that is true I mean so
I guess that's there's no other way for
Y to actually be able to to put more
pressure there other than trading Queens
so he said guys are of goes for the
Queen trade night takes and now of
course we have this kind of idea as I
mentioned f4 tried to take advantage of
that bond and Christopher you goes 495
all right Patrick Paoli mentioning kind
of a bizarre position the fifth-ranked
is entirely occupied I know
it's rare it's rare did you see
something like that for sure let's
listen to my favorite thing which is
yeah we always talk about centralizing
your pieces and it's it's tough to get
more central than those black tanks yeah
but so what's what would have happened
here after f4 I wonder why is it that
Sergey Seraph did not go for this move
was she worried the knight would go away
and the b2 would be hanging well let's
just play move Knight 9607 maybe
actually I think you're right and then
if we take maybe black would capture
this bishop first you never have to take
it back and now maybe capture here
things seem to be getting getting a bit
liquidated but that's true but the thing
is that black are not captured that
understand because there will be some
back rank maybe maybe not
I know we cannot take it we need to know
this real good here first
hmm Bishop e5 Knight might be a good
move for black kind of hemming in this
the threat for the moment in facts i
restricting that night yeah i don't
think it bit should be v really makes
the threat against through it because
there's always ricky eight if there is
ever attacked but things like rook c2
might might come very quickly and then
there's there's pressure on the juban
pressure on the king yeah and g5 as well
so a lot of a lot of ideas here so far
of course even though it might win a
pawn momentarily it does weaken the king
yeah that is true yeah you know you hear
people say you know when you play at
four of course that diagonal is weakened
from a7 to g1 but actually in end games
more relevant as sometimes the the
second rank really is weak dad it's true
pushing the F pawn the g2 pond is
obviously more accessible once that I've
found it's out of the way so circa
reservist putting a little bit more
pressure he's saying I can play F for
pretty much any time let me try to
improve my final piece bring it into the
game get a little bit more pressure on
actually both central files because we
are talking about to kind of backwards
pawns I guess if you can call those like
you're sure and having the Knights in
front I mean certainly this one in d5
cannot be pushed away by a pawn but you
do lose the a six point then you can
have some pressures there and I believe
Christopher you played Bishop f8 in this
position and this is the current
position that we have well there's a
threat to the bishop in g5 so f4 is is
getting more and more tempting every
every move two passes but can we play it
now so f4 and out of seven I guess it's
just the same idea
but I feel like I could even just move
my bishop out of the way right what if I
just play Bishop h4 and now your bishops
not ready to capture on b2 another idea
that I had it's not maybe it's great but
it's kind of a cool like up see I'm
sorry not that one not that one
rook takes a capture d5 would this move
work is the question maybe we have to
take on mm-hmm
and if you take here and my ideas of
course there's this capture and then
yeah the rook takes in the rook takes c6
mate yes yes you don't want to take the
pin piece you want to leave it there
until black manages to unpin but this
looks suspiciously like checkmate h5 or
something kind of difficult yeah so I I
don't know you know after a 4 9 of 7 I
feel that activity 5 looks like because
if you try to capture with the rook
thinking well I'll have your knight
attacked maybe a little more clever but
I will still take here and then you're
in big trouble I think because what are
you going to do so what's your school
circle back to that for let's go see
what options there's some better options
here for black so okay all right here's
an idea what if I take your Bishop No
yeah all right sacrificing the exchange
but once you capture back with the pawn
my Knights are you know your fate the
fortress understanding for absent
today's about fortresses I think I
should have made a theme for every day
every day yesterday they can be maybe
some fortresses somehow I don't believe
in this yeah I mean the Knights can
actually be pushed away of course they
can be attacked by whites night or what
a shower or even some sacrifice
eventually
but but it could be something a little
bit annoying I think if if f4 were to be
played I wonder if there's any other
option here for black after f4 hmm
because technically you don't really
have a threat that big of a threat right
because if you're going to write my
night I take your fish shop and then
your night is going to be attacked and
it's kind of restricted so unless
capturing in d6 is going to lead to some
clear win so our problem with 9 f7 is
where it takes d5 right so how can we
try to solve that problem
maybe rook g6 is a move here just giving
the king of flight square and preparing
to to play Knight f7 also defending e6
now what remains to be seen is if I can
take probably no I don't think so
because if I take here I think you can
just take right oh wait I think so
probably you don't want to capture the
night you know in d7 becomes strong yeah
but yeah you can you can take one I can
maybe I can't get away with taking your
night here this looks kind of
interesting actually
f-for what no trillion I don't think
that should work
she's trying to defense you did talk
about second seventh or second rank
right so I feel that Trudy salmon would
get to be very annoying well I want to
play up a tree you want you want to do
the same idea we learned yesterday or
two days ago from Grenada my buddy
III works with f3 and there were six
there was someone else who didn't eat
six it was in the a group someone played
it against yeah I'm struggling to
remember who she was
let me cheat and look it up okay but
first no no no it was a guess harutunian
whoever beat her at onion yes move maybe
it was Fred Frederico
of course that was the game between
Federico Papa and to ground her routine
as you mmm-hmm but okay say you one day
you might be slightly far gone from
reality but this this would be it's
looking testy for black yes maybe black
is holding on it in the specific
variations but Christopher you
definitely has to be careful here and
sir yeas are up down actually to eight
minutes it seems he has not made a move
yet in this position versus the current
position we have on the board we're only
on move 27 so it was definitely gonna be
looking at some time pressure here
that's true we have seen him in a lot of
time trouble in this tournament you
still wanted those manage them well he's
a structure there so this could be he's
playing that some some players just have
that that's that you know Sixth Sense
with a shoe I and their intuition and
play you know perfect moves I think we
spend enough time on the skin maybe it's
time to check out what's going on in the
a group and actually do that here we
have our pairings for the a group coming
up mom - we have Seth you playing
against Grigory oprand Jeffrey Zhang is
against Varga Cobian and that'll be a
game to look out for
of course Jeffrey just a half point
behind Renacci nice he wins today he
might be able to close that gap
Sam stuff Ian is playing a very
interesting game against Victor Erdos as
well
Daniel NAR did skeet was against Alexis
aronia and our key matchup of the day is
of course of honest kibou zine against
Rina and Juma buyeth
the leader with five points out of seven
he actually has some small chance to
clinch the victory today in the a group
things really have to go his way though
he has to win Jeffery has to lose and
Sam and Daniel I think both have to draw
so yeah highly unlikely but possible and
we're not it seems to be down to one
minute on his clock it's it's crazy and
we have to say how Hanukkah bush and he
had an amazing start in this tournament
that first round win seemed he was on
Form seems he was playing very very yeah
and then after that he didn't really
quite have his tournament but today what
an interesting position we have here
this is a crazy imbalance and one that
should favor white should normally but
he's I don't know I think it should
favor white and we were just talking I
think it all comes down to King's safety
here right yeah which can be safer I
would say wise King for the moment but
there are some ideas so why does this
imbalance we're talking about we have
two rooks and a pawn for three pieces I
mean that should certainly be better
like two points let's do some added that
5 Plus 5 is 10 plus 1 is 11 and the two
bishops and the knight of course only
worth 9 but it's it's about King safety
and it's about peace coordination and
here I think both favor white the rooks
are working together there they have
already invaded the black camp and
meanwhile the the black pieces while
they are sort of defending each other
that they're not really working towards
it towards the goal yeah and black
actually just made the move Queen to a7
I'm I have to say I'm really surprised
to see Jim abaya
in time trouble I have not really seen
him in that much of a time travel no we
were talking him up at the top of the
hour with with you know he's never been
worse see he's always got plenty of time
he's like a lot of a lot of things
though yeah I think actually in a great
position earlier on today
No and here's what happened this I think
to be clear I think this is winning for
white should be I mean I don't really
see it I mean there are a couple of
threats but like for example getting the
Queen to a one trying to bring the
Knight to g4 f3 maybe try to trap
White's King in the corner but this is
wishful thinking though wishful thinking
of course but you know you have to try
to create some ideas for yourself and
it's of course very unpleasant to to
have to play with one minute three more
moves to play and with your opponent
having 30 minutes on the clock
imagine you know how stressful this this
can be for your nut Jumma by if you I
don't think we can talk about the win
here unless he gets somehow a miracle I
mean that this is the type of position
where white could blunder yeah there are
some threats against the white king but
barring any you know any tragedies this
is quite well for Keynesian so which
move would you say we should go back to
to look at what went wrong do you have a
specific moment so go back in time maybe
around most so i winking after yeah move
29th c5 I thought Ranaut was was
coordinating his pieces quite well he
was evicting the white rook from b7 and
I thought that this was was actually
going to be a slightly favorable for
black yeah I mean black does have
slightly more space on the Kings side in
the center he has the pair of bishops
which of course is also very important
and it seems like he has made I really
like blacks next move as well d5
yeah trying to get a little bit more
space I like it for sure
and opening up the position when you
have the pair of bishops you should do
that yes let me see this 95 and that
actually struck me as kind of odd 97 or
95 night night b5 I thought it was it
was time for white to challenge this
Center I thought maybe the move d4 was
going to be played because after Knight
b5 I think you know black just just has
too many options to start opening things
up for those
mm-hmm so d4 looks like a very
interesting option typically yeah you
want to try to put your paws on dark
square and yet cement that the black
pawns on a square root Bishop can attack
them of course it does give up some
light squares but you do have this light
squared Bishop to compensate for it
maybe maybe night 94 was going to be a
black saucer in this position yes you
want to think I just want to capture it
the Knights yeah like this mm-hmm
and then maybe I can play well I wanted
to play like Queen deep it seems like D
take C yeah this should be this should
be the way to go
yeah I thought Queen B - but that
actually traps my queen that is not the
way okay - is going to be kind of
annoying I'm not so sure about this d4
move you have to be a little bit careful
you know God boozing in this tournament
in the games that he ended up losing I
noticed he did push the pawns a lot he
created some holes for yourself and he's
an aggressive player but he has to be
careful with the pawn pushes maybe he
was trying to do that I don't know if
I'm ready to give up on this line just
okay I can play Queen e1 and my idea is
simply I want to take e5 and I want to
put a knight on d4 and I think that's
going to be enough to cover my position
and from there I can start invading with
my rugs it seems a bit slow so what if
for example I play either looks u2 or
okay - I can't make up my mind well if
you play rook C - I think I've looked b8
okay and then I have to retreat or
Bishop there okay so I wanted to take on
e5 and play 94 against her okay too
yeah I assumed Bishop e5 but maybe I was
wrong yeah no I was going to play rook
c2 I always wanted rook c2 but but you
always have this robe b8 and then you
should see it I'm not sure if it's
sufficient this is kind of my idea right
just cover that and then try to take
advantage of my two rooks on the second
rank of course think I can even play
this one if I think that's what you
should do I don't think night 94 any
working but mm-hmm yeah the problem is
when the rooks get too active on
attacking like a me you start to live
your own King behind right this yeah oh
we actually have some key news in
groupie Emilio Cordoba has actually won
his game against Justin Wang this moves
Emilio actually into soul first place
with five and a half out of eight the
only one of the leaders going in into
today's round perhaps this is the game
that sets them apart yeah and I think
we're gonna try to have him come down
here and walk us through the game today
it seems like the games are finishing a
little faster used to be a right time
for commentary but maybe yeah and it's
going to be interesting to see his
thoughts on his game and actually check
it out since that's a game that we
didn't really look at but yeah well yeah
I just wanted to do with you maybe we
should get back to it some what actually
happened in the game but it is it is for
sure interesting but you have to be
careful on how you push the pause for
sure
I do like it I don't really see it at
this point yeah definitely definitely
it creates weaknesses though yes always
something to be wary of but maybe five
yes does seems a little bit stirs maybe
here's preparing to play d4 he wanted in
case of a trade to have the both both
nights there somehow maybe or who knows
although you know with the 19 b5 you're
not really controlling e4 that was the
but now is the night left now even you
know it was like okay no way no yeah
this is what happens he was like so now
he's basically trying to do the same
thing but maybe he thought the 19 b5
would be helpful for him and then Knight
to f4 Bishop f7 and Bishop f1 all right
so he's improving his pieces a little
bit now that that Dagon Olga
locked down by those pawns but this is
good for white because blacks bishops
they need open diagonals yeah right now
we just got them closed so so maybe not
really had to play a bit more quickly in
the center maybe he had to do something
like D for himself or try to play you
for him maybe then 97 was in the best
approach or maybe he thought he would
get some some attacking ideas and he
could have missed the 865 very
interesting temporary you know sacrifice
but now there's this 93 discovery and
white is going to be able to like for
example if you go room d6 I think takes
takes and Bishop c4 yeah then you have
to give them change instead of the other
thing that happened in the game right
well while you catch up with present-day
in this game I'm actually gonna step out
of my chair again yeah I believe we have
Emilio Cordova ready she is a very
important win in the B group all right
so let's let's take a look how we have
reached the current position in the in
this game so rook takes c3 Queen takes
c3 rooks is 6 so black thought okay I
still have to two pieces but he probably
missed this nice Bishop c4 move and now
things are getting traded and it could
go and Weiss favors after King age 7
okay so now I can see how we got into
that position so black decided to
sacrifice another exchange but this
should really be better for white and
now rooks e1 protecting the rook King g6
and we are reaching the current position
alright but we do have grandmaster
Emilio Cordova with us today
very nice win congratulations thank you
we haven't had the chance to to go over
over your game yet tell us how do you
feel how do you feel
about how do you feel about the
tournament right now you just took the
lead after the after the win yeah didn't
have a good start in the tournament but
yeah yeah it was so terrible I must say
but they have some walk and back luck
too because yeah as I said before the
second round I couldn't play yeah
because I was losing since the first aid
move so and yesterday I was kind of
walking so I'd say okay maybe I have to
walk by my side too so I just changed
luck change maybe I did something yeah
yeah I don't know maybe just more
positive positive I mean today I was
kind of lucky to I guess because
probably singing should be draw but
somehow I I had a feelin that I I know I
have no risk so that was my goal that
played for free and yeah and
unfortunately for Justin he played this
h3 which is I think it's losing yeah
looks natural to trade pawns when you
are when you have a bad decision but I
mean probably the plan the right plan
should be like we should have permission
to at some point but I wasn't so sure
because the capture and before it's kind
of hard but definitely because Bishop c2
was a mistake too because now I have a
lot of extra ten people I don't know do
you think let's let's go back a little
bit from the beginning of the game -
sure did you have this line prepared
yeah some of these kids you see them
young and you're thinking okay they
don't know everything but then suddenly
yes Alou they know everything everything
yeah and I have a lot of energy and
confidence but this is theory for ya old
history and I remember I saw I think it
was favi against Evian that's why we
play g6 so I say okay why we play this
should be okay so yes a serious player I
guess I just follow his yeah in depth
and I think for our viewers I think it's
good to know that you know if you're
trying to play good line if you're
following some of the top players most
likely they have the stuff analyzed
likely yeah yeah not always not always
yes it bleeds for example they probably
don't show everything yes true sir I
thought that this position it's okay
it's okay for what at listen I think
this in general is good for waka Blackie
Cola is pretty simple
mm-hmm and you have this plans with f5
at some point yeah yes they're not
rushing yeah I mean at some point I just
can't play we shot this 6 and second if
I have some point not in this right now
yeah I guess the black position is to
solve it so yes but yeah then he just
played his plan which is very
interesting in each one and a four will
be three obviously I don't know if any 7
was the right move then I felt like okay
that can be lost to the c-54 square but
I don't know maybe it can improve a
little bit here yeah I mean I've seen it
I think I've seen it before
yes 36 and then maybe just come play
here a for I was thinking but okay maybe
I don't know I don't know if there is
any difference but because absolute
point okay my queen is is good only 7
but I don't know maybe I can try to do
something and you want to play with B 3
or a 3 I think these three 3s it makes
sense yeah trying to make sure why does
not get this this chain of yes
so if white have to play B 3 now ok now
white but there is no yes I think I tend
definitely black is ok here ok sorry
night yeah looks looks grey for black uh
please no dwarfs oh yeah that's why
probably Queenie said it was like I was
I was just playing past and then I
realized that okay it's natural but
probably no the most precise I think you
always have a fourth white is going to
play b3 you always have yeah so maybe it
don't need to necessarily
yes yeah but the Stila I feel like
Queenie 7 I don't know disappointing
yeah okay so yeah foreign yes I'm very
typical yeah I know that it's pretty
common but suddenly I just missed this
nicely to to be honest
I mean he captured everything okay today
can I see - I just miss this so I
thought maybe I have to capture in the
five and try to play for a draw but then
I decided okay I have a pair of fishes I
should try it
yeah there is no necessity to play for a
draw here okay probably objectively draw
but I thought that maybe with the pair
of fishes at least I should have pretty
good compensation for you why tonight
here in d5 is yeah but it doesn't do
anything
yeah yeah it's just and now you got rid
of you know with that trade you got rid
of your backwards pawning - yes now you
have any five but it's a possible yeah
yeah actually that will help me a lot
yeah I can see the final position for
sure yes I saw this bishop the bishop
before which is kind of the I don't know
if it's good but at least looks like why
needs to trade everything on before
mm-hmm otherwise he's worse and I saw
these angling with a pair of Bishops
okay okay maybe here and I have
something Rudy - maybe this was a it
wasn't the best but where I think the -
actually the only person reason because
he freaky one rupee eight rooks ey looks
like very strange yeah that's true
yeah looks like almost like he's winning
so it really - I thought I was winning
actually here I said okay I'm winning
but then I realized that he was not so
simple
yeah this is canon now Knights of four
yes keeping your bishop away but g5 okay
the knight doesn't stay there too long I
thought you would come back yes because
you have to play g4 to open up your
bishop yeah
now 94 and the first line that I saw it
was a rookie wanking of - I thought
Keinath - but then I saw this me should
have won but and after we should have
won I don't know I was kind of worried
to be honest okay looks treaty but I
didn't know it's not gonna be enough if
you take here and look here I'm just
asking I don't know yeah maybe
not maybe somehow he can get the rookin
game yeah I was afraid of the Reuben
game to be honest maybe this is still is
good for black objectively because I
would take the porn and black has no
risk but I thought maybe just can't
improve my keen position a little bit
more yeah I think you should probably
shouldn't rush because you have such a
good such a good yeah pressure and
pressure and you can take that night
anytime you want so paint and it's not
so clear for white to make a move yeah
and and he has this protected postponed
but going forward I mean it's not going
to yeah yeah so it's good there but for
freaking important game that would be
great but he did not get the chance to
take it I guess yeah to get into that
you're improving your position and then
finally I decided it's the right time
there's no more improvement for me yeah
that I thought that Keaney five maybe
was an option but then I saw this be
sure to age seven and I wasn't so I
wasn't sure about this line so it looks
mighty realistic but okay it's a boy
yeah I mean this will be will be weak at
some point maybe yeah I was thinking
ricochet but then I saw something like I
don't know Bishop c2 once again yeah
because when you take their yeah now I
need my keen on f6 yeah yeah and I
realized that okay maybe I'm afraid
because I saw this Bishop c2 looks like
not natural this because he's not
covering maybe he should have one maybe
I was thinking yeah you should have one
and wait for a rookie for and then tried
to trade everything and getting into the
routine but just go back up or maybe run
these free but then I can take on a four
and see back I wonder if you can take
with the rook ah you can take with the
pitch I can wait okay well I don't know
it looks nice he'll they take on h2
right yeah yeah you have a lot of pawns
yeah that looks like that and I think it
works it to Bishop h2 and one does
policy but you know I should be winning
should be winning I guess
no sweetheart maybe it's five yeah I was
thinking just capture and they just do
maybe so but the oh yeah yeah right
maybe have to push the pause maybe you
can bring the King now yeah born and
then go with that phone it should be
just nice but it looks nice it mister be
calculated that's just but okay it but
Bishop c2 simply allows this yeah and
it's like white cannot move so that was
my position yeah no I just completely
okie three with an extra temple maybe
here the only move was Bishop do you
want I guess and try once again to play
this looking game I have to I don't know
if I have to take or rookie for first I
wasn't sure and then rookie for before
and yeah
so then king of five and I named from in
my position repeat three so I guess what
at least has because I saw this planet
rookie three Brooks III and suits fine
yeah certainly certainly a beautiful
game and now you're you're the leader of
the tournament you have one more round
yeah for the moment there's someone some
more games that can catch up with your
yeah at least I would try to play my
best and try to play more accurate and
not to either because it was so
embarrassing
so yeah it happens to everyone yeah
everyone knows at some point you will
blunder just need to come back from it
and yeah at least it was no so bad at
all so and just kind of happy with my
results for sure I was winning against
the other roof
it was a crazy yeah yeah it was like
okay I saw this Queen age five which was
a winning move but then I said okay
maybe I just can't improve my pieces and
then maybe then you helped here yeah
yeah actually yeah I miss Queen mystery
that was the problem so I say oh my god
yeah I means this and then I just
started to collapse but okay yesterday
was lucky so it was like
I can say that even it's even right all
right yes that's true well thank you so
much for joining us today we wish you
good luck in the last round it's getting
really exciting and yeah thanks for
joining us yeah
thank you all right that was Grandmaster
Emilio Cordova leading currently leading
the big group and and now we have on the
screen grandmaster Renato mabye of
thinking about his very difficult
position they were talking about a
little bit earlier
what an interesting position we have
still why this clearly doesn't see my
black has any counter play in my opinion
here so I think we're going wait wait a
second let's think maybe f3 after you
check we need to see it but I feel the
gap region has calculated this and he
does not the king g3 for the moment yeah
it's gonna be back by the way a great
interview feels great yeah this is this
caught my eye I got excited it was nice
to to hear him you know discuss the game
I went a little bit over time I think
yeah it was interesting to hear his
thoughts also about his tournament and
how he must have some things we were
right about some things in his previous
games many ways back to this very
interesting positions I was white not
checkmated I don't see it I don't know I
just feel like he should have calculated
something why would he get into this
position if he didn't calculate so one
of the two legal moves on the board I'll
let you pick what is happening this is
the key to win in analysis you always
pick the side this winning all right I
cannot believe what what just happened
they cool I guess can you age 3 yeah
that's what I was thinking
my father's night up too and this this
is your dad you're just
I am the queen g1 let's meet ya night h3
isn't a no this is made in the queen g4
is me
oh yeah 93 is not me what what are we
missing what is what's happening I'm
confused
is this the correct position are we
having the correct position Kim G 3 that
was impossible
yeah I don't know I don't know I thought
white was supposed to be clearly winning
so Kim G 3
is there made queen g1 check I go King
to f4 and then what do you do wait wait
there's no me there's no major trying to
chase me
oh the e pond is saying yeah Bishop h6
was made no okay I freaked out for a
second I was also I'm not reaching for
anyone here I guys are just trying to
you know just evaluating the positions
I'm like white was winning so first I'm
rooting for composing cuz it makes that
it makes the last round much more
interesting okay Rinat has had some work
to do to catch up by the time did he
just make a move to play f3 he has
played f3 has been played on the board
so this is the current position guys f3
and we're anticipating huge e3 I mean
right yeah he's about to he's about to
amazing king to g3 okay has been
calculated supposedly I mean he didn't
have 30 minutes yeah and some point you
have to have to trust it he's a very
strong player okay right now does not
look very happy yes I I can't
wow I don't know if I would have yeah
the way with all its playing like this
with weight it's tough I mean there's
always you know at some point you have
to trust your calculation but this this
is very scary looking but I think it all
works out for weight you know everything
is so interesting because we just pick
this games we we say what do we think
about the players yes we seem to be
picking a side and then when we actually
pick the side the person is to mess up
or something I mean well if he
calculated this well then he's doing no
no what I was saying is we talked about
Renaud Juma by of having not made a
single mistake in this chart I'm not the
single mistake but like the commentators
curse right yeah I mean he had a very
good tournament so far most of his
positions were balanced or better we
didn't really see him in difficulty in
this tournament he had a beautiful win
against Jeffrey shown yesterday he
missed some chances against Sam Savion
but but now clearly had a better
position we thought around
twenty-something and now he gets into
this position where things crumbled his
pieces are not coordinated he's going to
lose the a for the e4 pawn in the center
and so yeah we should mention that the
reason why this should be winning for
white if black isn't checkmating is the
second the black stops checking the
white king white is just check menu
black in ten different ways yes six
check there's our g5 checker yeah so
many ideas you have to see which one
you're going to go forward to make sure
that King you will have no escape but
for sure if you stop the checks it will
be over
so this we are anticipating a win for of
Hondas compose ian and maybe if that
were to happen the whole standing
channel change and blows the tournaments
wide open and I believe we should maybe
check on some of those those games of
the other players in the a group who are
probably watching this game quite
closely I think so for example what's
going on with Jackson Zhang today
against vara Cobian Chris McKay
Geoffrion for an interview yesterday
after a very nice come win sort of
rebounding after that loss to Rinna the
sixth round I believe and he said in
that interview that's far as someone who
struggles with mentioned that and all
devar did have a tough tournament so far
he's not someone to count out you know
he's played a lot of US Championships
has represented the US Olympic team a
few times I think also and for sure one
of the favorites here and at the San
Luis chess club but Jeffrey also so we
have two Americans there were besides
for sure but I believe taking a look at
the clocks they're actually in quite
severe time pressure is some some who's
actually coming in here is they have
seven moves left to make to make the 40
move time control and black does have an
extra point in this position
God black is struggling with their
bishop in d7 and white has the pair of
bishops white also has the control over
the B file I mean
I would say white a slightly better
because well has plenty of conversation
we should say it that way
I always forget because I just these
days it's whether I better or not you
look at the engine and you're saying
well there is a plus for X or Y meaning
white or black and then you take a side
but here white pieces are so much better
placed black special 57 is struggling
the rook is still in a8 some good pieces
of blacks of course our district in 82
in the nineteen d5 but absolutely will
he be able to do so the key for Jeffrey
right is to find some way to open up the
position right that's that's how you
really make use of the bishops so right
now black has this kind of light square
defense going on with this knight on d5
and this pawn on e6 and c6 but if like
you kind of shake loose these pawns them
health and bishops will become dangerous
that will be kind of tough because
definitely four is going to weaken this
great chain of post that you have built
yeah I was hoping to just play eat four
directly oh and perhaps this opens up
that that c2 to h7 f b1 h7 diagonal as
well as the e-file it does weaken my d4
upon and this is the the downside a very
interesting decision pushing that pawn I
was not considering that and all in this
position maybe I can take uh yeah and I
don't know I just thought this would
activate my bishop a bit more of course
you're okay for might be an option now
but yeah interesting interesting
position yeah
did they make sometimes I do want to
mention as this game progresses here I
believe we are actually going to get
Federico poncy in for an interview
he has just drawn his game against Melek
stop Sheehan and that brings him to five
out of eight just a half point behind
the leader
Emilio Cordova going into the final
round okay yeah that's in the seventh
its we have never had him before for an
interview so
unfortunately you have to leave me again
these are always the most painful
moments I have to make sure I'm doing a
right commentary by myself
all right as Frederick up our sponsor is
going to get set up in our studio we
have seen a few more games in this
Jeffrey's shown against Morocco beyond
game Bishop C - okay - King f1 was
played by Jeffrey he's trying to improve
the position of his King and var decided
to go ahead and push the pawns on the
Kings side in order to try to open up
the each file I'm thinking he might try
some King f7 get the rook on the edge
well try to get some activity maybe go
for f2 but as we are waiting for those
moves to be played we have in the studio
Grandmaster para sponsor Frederico who
has drawn he's came today thanks for
joining us tell us about your feeling
about the tournament and today's game
being one of the you know close to the
leader of the tournament sorry it's good
I mean it's a bit surprising that only
with +2 we are living
I mean shared leaning but still today's
game I know no I think it was more or
less correct there was two or three
moments where we had some difficult
decision to make but I didn't see
anything
dangerous either for me or for him so
probably draw was was fine do you want
to point point out those moments of
fortune having had time to look at at
your game yes sure well then we can go
from there from the behavior I was
expecting he would play this Bishop b5
check and he takes 93 he played this a
lot of times so when I was preparing I
saw this idea with E 5 the problem is if
I start with rook c8 he can play e5 I
think that's again for option design
it's quite good so if I has to be played
first just yeah sure yeah when d3 rook
c8 Castle and quinces and
the idea is try trying to not play at
six too fast I mean usually I want to
play a six so I can play Knight f6 and
Bishop g5 is not a problem so he can
take over 95 mm-hmm so here there's a
game young against I shared a graph it
was the same day for Bishop eazy-e six
rugby one I just want to mention they
actually have a result in the group Juma
by gabbatha boys Ian just won his game
against Iran to my bias so that kind of
takes me not from the lead he was
leading the tournament and now maybe
some interesting things are going to
happen and it's a little bit open yet
that was a very impressive game and we
might have Capozzi on join us for an
interview later but let's see so this is
pretty yeah so this was theory on the
game my chair was not instead of Bishop
c5 92 little ideas to go F 1 so Bishop
concern
91 in Quincy for I was more or less
happy to to play this young him he can
take over 393 like should be yeah it's
not so easy I mean yeah Britain might
say slight advantage for white but I'll
just take with the Commission I guess
with the rook force of three and then
maybe 97 g6 of five something like that
play on the side of the road
yeah would be more or less equal to me
yeah so q1 Bishop c5 so now I can play
another try that's why the order I went
Queen c7 yes so that you don't stay
tuned so I don't know the worried about
ideas been 95 no because I guess I take
in the 96 and then I go back I can takes
it to something yeah yeah maybe I can
protect you - yeah he went rogue 81 yeah
just not sure maybe he was 95 yeah so I
went 36 Bishop e3 I went back this is
all normal and now I wasn't sure what he
would do because he complained at age 4
maybe mm-hmm and I don't know if I
should play Quincy 46 maybe both are
okay
I knew this hand game was in general
players so I want to take advantage of
those two polls yeah they for so maybe
it's okay 192 bishop
95 and this is the first moment I have a
big choice with what you're gonna take
tonight yeah I can take with the night
I'm gonna shop d7 I can stay with a
Nikon Bishop g4 mm-hmm
and I can take with the bishop like I
did but here I thought if normally I
would take with the night and tried to
play Bishop d7 g7 and then play yeah but
he can play b3 I think and then the idea
is when I play a 5 he will pee for ya
and he can play nicely for us with an a5
maybe so my wish upon this urn is really
well I mean just stabilize the position
and yeah and your two bishops don't do
so much of yeah this is actually I don't
know maybe it's good for him I thought
for a while here and decided to if if a
five maybe something yeah at some point
but he complain I see four first and
wait of it so so I like to go in the
bishop and then 94 to is because if he
plays a free than they should be well
now you're gonna take the I will take
the bishop he can play Bishop e7 I
thought this for a while but then I
would be ship g5 I think yeah I think
you want to get rid of that yes I want
to take I goes back with the knight
should be fine for me yeah yeah but then
he went c4 - he went c4 very fast now he
took with the pond which I thought it
was a bit surprising maybe maybe he did
maybe this is just very close to equal
sometimes I can even be better if I go
away five mm-hmm and then a five so at
least I can push my pawns okay but the
castle Ruka for Melissa and b3 and here
I don't know I could play a five as well
this is the second time but before words
are bit annoying and then you have to
again make a decision yeah because I can
play Bishop g5 takes and takes on d2 and
then takes on a five
I mean context oh wait yeah Bishop takes
two then I take on the five and then he
takes and maybe Ruth one
I don't know maybe it's our own equal
looks like we have another result same
seven true against Victor our doors we
might have one of those coming later
while I'm not sure
wait he can play another three because
of before but he had play this is
beautiful actually
but and then again I could play we
should be seven back I know yeah but the
night you probably don't like the night
there you know because maybe he would go
back I mean I'm no Wi-Fi but okay I felt
I should be playing for something more
here I mean maybe he can even play
ninety three and then after Bishop she
was Roxy to or something to thank for my
Roxy to Andrew Gough to
but I just wonder five and here all
chairs but let's see if I was I didn't
expect see for okay
I thought maybe a five maybe before
mm-hmm now and now he's he's trying just
buying different ships he's okay I mean
actually I was a bit worried at some
point after Queen e6 look if they were
look of the 825 on now my idea was to
take him Brooks e6 but that doesn't work
no I think a night a yes and then I
wanted to play g6 I think but then he
can take on c5 which rock that's really
the Seawind me to force me I know but if
I trade kicker groups erupts his MO and
this is probably pretty balanced no but
maybe he can take b7 uh-huh try to get
on seventh ranked sure and then I go
route you are Ruby to and his king is it
should be equal I don't know yeah but
thinking of seven looks nice and then I
don't know I felt at some point I had a
champ at
sprawl is always a row jiff yeah g4 is
good yeah trying to because if I take
then he was look at one and look I don't
know if I go King e6 or King g6 but he
then he takes two six two five I thought
this would be dangerous for me okay I
mean Mary is still liquid but but wait
why do you have to do this know the
program is are
the first time I didn't see what to do
after context because if context work
everyone
I'm probably oh but but I can take on
the six first mm-hmm with the trade so
he takes on d6 I'm taking g6 and then I
can take three six first try to then
what you don't need to take it yes I
gotta be twenty-five and I can also
probably play King takes on route d3
mm-hmm should be draw I mean okay but he
was playing for a win here I mean g4 he
can probably take up c5 he wants to the
robot he tried you for after and yeah
this this game seems like it's requires
a lot of a lot of analysis of very
interesting broken game unfortunately
you got a person with our show so yeah
thank you for going going through all of
these lines with us well we'll try to
keep looking I guess after after this it
was more or less for us I mean you can
just go Tilian yeah it's probably
without but is certainly a very tension
tension game and both of you are trying
to fight for a win in the way around
yeah it's it's kind of kind of
interesting thanks for so much for
joining us we wish you good luck
tomorrow's a tough tough game you're
used to
thank you thanks for joining us and all
right that was Grandmaster Paris phone
Sam
what an interesting games they had and I
believe we might have Grandmaster
Debussy and possibly joining us
maybe not yes he's here alright so he's
going to get set up what
what an interesting game that was we
were right with Caleb there was no made
for black white was the only one trying
to not rank we was winning in that
position so let's see how harness let's
see his thoughts
congrats from this game thanks for
joining us again what happened with you
in the tournament you started so great
has a beautiful first I don't know it's
disaster I'm losing call Doris positions
I can't beat positions were advantage so
final today it happened or it was a
tough game so I can't say it I had a big
advantage old again but at some point I
guess my opponent me played something so
I got some activity we were we you you
change the standings in this tournament
right I mean no it's possible if
Geoffrey's winning he might be taking
the lead
oh yeah probably I think about the same
cousin right now I'm if I think for
anything now you're like I'm going to
that makes sense and we were thinking
around this position we when you know
your opponent played d5 trying to get
some space here and you play this move
95 that way we were wondering was there
a reason why I didn't go for and I don't
wanted to get this pawn structure
because what I'm trying to do to get the
first square and trying to force d5 poem
so I play tonight before the reason I
want to play d4 uh-huh and just for
example after some 84 hours I'm gonna go
Queen d1 or a queen e1 and just keep
this d4 square so later I will if you
make some random of save some strengths
then you move or something there before
and me probably Queen D one I don't know
you want or do what they can't have a
great night on the force yes I was
aiming for these central squares and
actually I did want to allow a man to
play for and like to have a pawn on e4
and close my bishop I see okay we
weren't sure in this position how to
evaluate it if during the game I wasn't
sure whether I'm playing for I wanted to
I'm trying to hold it so I decided well
of course I haven't known might be 5k to
be the best move in real but but 97
seemed to to have kind of let you do
what you wanted 97 I guess is a were
strong move because what's my problem
Knight is going to f6 and protecting d5
pawn and aiming for this g4 would square
in the future so I miss F at 97 isn't a
good move but whenever he played it on
d4 e4r it happened in the game AHA here
I wasn't really happy cuz next Knight f6
is coming so well and here was a crazy
play and dr. Knight f6 it was really
hard to play certain g5 is coming Knight
g4 any future so you probably rushed in
this position yeah I think so Knight f6
first levels better and I don't know
what I was going to he writes I move
Knight c3 or something but I was gonna
so it's better you're telling us it's
better to keep the tensions yeah for
sure cuz after g5
what's the problem with Korea I'm gonna
give two pieces for your home but the
key positions were open so black ink is
gonna get under Italian yeah there was
that was his problem and after dad like
you played really really nice and I
don't know if you had any moment if
there was only one point the good chance
so here we ship c4 mm-hmm I guess he was
trying to play for a winking gauge 7
Queen b3 is our only moves and here are
up Seaford Seaford now he played Knight
f6 so our blue trying to fight but what
I'm thinking about the black can't have
really here's the in chances for a win
so I think my opponent decided to fight
cuz Knight b6 is making probably a door
here I have to take when b6 takes takes
and takes from c4 oh yeah I will try to
make something here but I'm not sure
they're ever tried to push my deep own
somehow but I'm not sure it's gonna be a
temptation oh well after Knight f6 it
was really we were we are Egyptian that
we're watching man chances so of course
he's going for it to weaken making with
f4 but I guess we ship c4 instead of my
farmers gonna take rook c4 and next move
just play rook c5 after 4 so that's what
they were thinking about so this is
breath works yeah and I'm gonna take
work g5 shake when I fly out there are
many threats so the probabilities is
already but they are after Knight f6 and
yeah how deputy in the game is just lost
yeah yeah that's tell us tell us your
secret last question that I have for you
for today it's it's a very interesting
day we're having a lot of interviews but
what's your secret how do you play so
fast
do not spend enough time well I'm
getting this question weary often okay I
don't have the only answer so it depends
well this is my style so I'm trying to
use my opponents time and usually if you
notice all my opponents are getting in
time troubles yes my Trump I mean even
India cool positions or even in the bad
positions here are at many cases when I
was completely lost like - five six -
correct position but because of time
travel of my opponent some chances and
today yep of course I can so you try are
basically for like a poker player yes
everything is my opponent I'm in the
opening so yeah it's good that you're
managing because not every round many
just use the opponent's time right -
over to calculate say if this might
start to do this with in trying to do
all right well you heard him you can try
to actually know some some players in
the US who are following your style so
this is cool well thanks for joining us
today
again we wish you good luck last round
try your best no you're not in the
contention but you never know all right
to be important thank you very nice come
back into the tournament or a beautiful
way win against the leader of the
tournament so caboose Ian of Hondas has
beaten drainage from above
today and we are going to see some
changes in the standings and I believe
we're going to have another player from
the a section that we've never had
before in the tournament
Sam Savion is going to join us for the
first time and I believe this was a very
interesting game unfortunately with all
the interviews and with getting in a
little bit later than the game started
we haven't had the chance to go over the
key moments of your gamesome but maybe
you can walk us I heard there was some
sacrifice yeah this was a very
interesting game he played some
variation okay let's let's get back to
the opening all right
were you prepared is this this wasn't my
main line okay so that's good I guess
going into your preparation and for
those of you who want to make a draw
guys you can always just repeat here and
hope that black is going to go for
rookie eight yeah I guess it's like me
are you wait oh you did it again you're
like let's be some risk in some time and
make sure that all right it's not as
good I mean you never know when you
might need that extra time yeah okay
did you play them fast did you play the
most fast I was making sure he doesn't
have deferred all right
okay so closing your position and now
the bane idea for black is to move the
net in don't play c6 mm-hmm and white -
is that of 183 but he played this very
interesting move 95 which I didn't know
so Bishop 82 and the ideas after Bishop
a2 or Bishop t2 he wants to go c6 uh-huh
yeah and I basically spend a lot of time
deciding between winning the piece with
before mm-hmm or just taking on c6 which
maybe I should have taken on c6 but the
thing is he plays Bishop 66 actually
it's very interesting if I play d4 here
he goes night c4 Oh
Knight takes e4 BC 92 which was I was
yeah and he plays d5 here and I was
considering many moves CED but I'm under
attack after Queen takes d5 or 97 this
just isn't so I mean you have a lot of
pieces on you should not maybe I should
put this should be 2 instead of be 65 oh
here
yes should you find
just try to keep the tension doesn't
really want to take D because then they
take c4 yeah is going to be completely
blocked but okay very interesting yeah
so maybe we should be - that would give
you some some maybe I should say the
same but but they think it doesn't just
doesn't feel comfortable to place your
bishop there yet although those funds
will be traded at some point you'll take
C for you you'll play eventually please
restate your actually and defends the c1
it's not clear what it wouldn't expose I
should play Queen c2 Lube do you want
something that's the same thing that
couldn't be six it and the eight or
something yeah all right so a lot of
pressures but he you went for before he
went for the piece do you think he had
this planned
did he play fast was this you may have I
don't know there's also sixty-five here
which is kind of the key point I think
night c4 Knight takes e4 BC Bishop takes
e4 rook c8
couldn't be three I was trying to make
this work for a long time trying to hold
on to both pawns III and I think we had
the result in the game Jeffrey's younger
gains for Akopian I do not know what the
result was probably a draw okay we're
still we're still waiting to see the
Kings being placed okay that was a draw
like resigned a fruit yeah I was like
what happened all right
it was supposed to be a draw I mean it
was pretty balanced so now we have to
leave yeah yeah
Jeffery and Aaron and my wife okay wait
so Queen b3 and do you think that and
your initially you think like maybe rook
takes c4 is interesting
Wow Queen takes c4 Knight takes d5 but
waits up in exchange so if Bishop d2 or
III so how did you make your decision
twenty-three point B 3 okay because a
very nice idea Quincy seven naturally
going for 982 mm-hmm and two nice plans
because one is Queen b8 Quinn eight and
I can't defend the deep on Oh because
now I have the 1982 bothering ever
singing yeah I think this is a very nice
and actually native one trying to put it
on you three Queen a 893 likewise Ruka
c7 and again I can't move to be shy go
trip do one rookie see it it looks like
I'm in time it should be too but once
[Music]
well so this is probably that's that's
crazy and I mean guys who are watching
this this video I mean look at these
grandmasters they're calculating so much
how do you calculate all this yes too
much time all right but you went for the
for the post after instead of Queen b8
after 92 all right so here no no no no
seven I did not supply 97 I think and
try to go for an explained as well yeah
so once I saw these things I'd say okay
I'm going through this for the piece
yeah and then he made a very nice move
d5 if you place Queen takes a file first
I play c4 and my pieces can breathe yeah
yeah we at some point your position did
not look very comfortable I think they'd
be through the mistake actually okay
I think I should go night f1 and play
for 93-94
an activity because my pieces on the
Quinn suggested holding on to the pawn
but this like this yeah what will you do
with their Bishop is he on himself
I really want to place it there it's not
so easy okay and then you struggled a
little bit yeah no black eyes ideally
black wants to put place to 1986
mmm-hmm and support g5g for break uh-huh
oh so that's fine yeah and that's maybe
the best move here isn't it h7
for black yeah try to bring it to
actually go for them to go to e6
mmm-hmm maybe he didn't realize that
that he could do that but maybe you have
ideas too I can play that Kirk 81 9 g5 +
23
choice to enter Queen b6 so there are
some IDs with us mm-hm
of course also f3 in many positions to
open the ticking say yeah this is this
this looks like a very complicated game
deferens actually likes to move to g6
take a lot of hours to analyze in depth
and see where where everyone went wrong
he's doing the same thing but he
weakened def 6 squared she comes in
which is important later on so I played
Queen it's a metaphor
one important moment if you please
insert another for f5 I go Queen b6
mm-hmm and then we're taking g6 and you
can't really play cranston because they
chief having finally I know and now you
can see how you should be very careful
of not pushing some many pawns
her being very careful of how you push
them all right and we have another
result so right now one against nerd
it's key wow so many crazy games today
this this tournament is changing a lot
of leaders I think wow all right just
the same we are approaching the end of
our time here so here I'm gonna let you
for okay I think matter of six first and
you can't really play Bishop you son
because of the c5 squared Queen b6 95
you start activating a lot of your
pieces review but rookie six and of
course I can do them too should be one
under previous one probably instead of
lady for just me yeah and you're both
going low on time I think I had about 23
minutes you he spend a lot of time like
25 minutes here
this is this is beautiful there you're
trying to actually undermine the the
protection in these two pawns and just
try to to kind of destroy you don't want
to keep this night in a 4-4-2 yeah it's
always annoying to have such an item
III suppose I just want to show one few
lines I think he should have played be
take c4 in this position and two lines
if 94 which I initially won Wow and
probably can I take yes take point 64
and this has problems if yeah and the
problem is at the end of your sacrifices
oh sorry no rook takes f6 Queen takes f6
Bishop g7 it looks like here's this nice
punching I trade everything in horse
mining c4 something I use the pin to
defy oh very beautiful okay now you take
problem and which one do start I guess
it should be winning and then everything
is lost so he has to be careful it is a
very nice move after 94 I think rookie 7
which is very turn into because it loves
native 6 chick for sure I mean I need
some time to adjust to the changes in
that position this 94 is very very nice
but after he takes it looks like you're
quitting man I just is there is there
going to be a difference I can take the
roof - honey 5 ah yeah ok but maybe so
let's a rope tasty a quintic c8 Quint
except for I could also take the rook in
deposition in 865 mm-hmm alright under
previous movements you want to take the
rook which Queen g5 I was looking at a
94 th 5 yeah I didn't like this that
much whoo okay lots of lines too much
too many lines for me but you're abled
in the end to kind of equalize once the
the final so I was retakes f4 and then
before I think everything
and then yesterday cheat just traded
everything so you want to descend game
yeah notice it takes and now you don't
really have a maid you need you need a
pond there please hit me with you has a
nice draw rook c8 Haruka c1 chicken ribs
c7 Oh beautiful okay so now he's forcing
possibly the rook trades okay but but a
very a very hard-fought game certainly a
lot to learn for everyone and maybe a
new idea I was sacrificing a piece and
creating some very annoying plans in the
center thank you so much for joining us
today and walking us through all these
lines unfortunately our show will have
to end very soon so we wish you good
luck and last round whom do you have
last round yeah
alright so we're gonna take a look at
the standings and see what is happening
here today thank you again Sam for
joining us so in Group A we have Renaud
Yuma life he lost this game he's still
in the living position with Jeffrey
Zhong who drew his game and we have them
both at five points third is Sam seven
with his drawers secured he starts third
place and he's really putting a lot of
pressure on those two Renaud and Jeffrey
for the last going into the last round
then we have Daniel narrowed its key one
of the you know players who was about
leaving the tournament had a great
tournament but unfortunately lost today
against Alexey Serena who's catching up
and Caleb is joining me back so I'm
going to let you oh yeah I get to do all
the interviews I get to read the
students of course you were a lovely
interviewer oh my so many interesting
games and I feel bad we didn't really
have the time to go over all the game
yes how do our finishing towards the end
of them we wanted to get more interviews
because some of those players had a
great tournament and we have
never had the chance order to get them
down course or some thoughts of course
our show tomorrow we will be staying on
until all is decided so be sure to tune
in for that maybe we'll have some time
to get some of those players in of
course just jumping back to that that a
group for a moment here
Rinat you mabye of jeffrey zhang the two
players at the top of course Sam 7
definitely within striking distance yes
with an outside chance
Daniel Norton ski and Alexis Tirana also
able to catch those leaders be on the
lookout for that vernaccia mabye of game
tomorrow and the Jeffrey jean game
tomorrow those are likely the two to
decide it yeah and and the Thurman is
still playing Gregorio parents so if one
of them is going to win the game they
can join Sam for third place that games
still in progress so it's going to be
pieces on the board a lot left to be
decided there
yeah and time is going down so yes well
why don't we check out the B group
standings as well let's do that after a
couple results today Emilio Cordova has
actually won his game launching him into
clear first place for the moment behind
him trails federico poncy which is five
points just a half point outside of the
lead and of course Sergei azeroth has
four and a half out of seven so if he
manages to beat Christopher you and what
seems to be an opposite colored Bishop
end game he will be joining Emilio at
the top of the leaderboard however I'm
expecting to draw from that game likely
two players just a half point behind
Emilio going into this final round Alexi
Sorokin unfortunately lost today -
Emilio Cordova oh no I'm sorry - all
Sean maratti about yeah that was a our
first beautiful game yes of course Alexi
be on the lookout for his game tomorrow
if he wins tomorrow he will be making
his grand master title you know chief
his final norm and go home with that
very nice title Melancon she drew today
bring him to four and a half points
figure out her route Union is still
playing yes yeah
and just a quick prediction on that game
looks to be a drawn rook end game so
expecting a draw there for her
let me see the players they're still
battling it out this one
- but fairly simple drill yeah I think I
think so we had that one of those
yesterday in the game between Markovian
and opponents oh yeah yeah I mean at
this level I think players should know
how to drive cross positions ulzzang
improves his score to three and a half
just annoying still on two and a half in
circuit Arenberg and christopher you
round out the B group of course I want
to mention tomorrow the round starts two
hours early as does our show so be sure
to tune in live tomorrow at 1:30 p.m.
Central Time we will both be here to
give you the final round coverage and
note that if any players tie for the
lead we will be having playoffs tomorrow
yes so be sure to stay tuned our show
will will stay on until all is decided
tomorrow so it'll be an extra long one
hopefully an extra entertaining one with
everything being decided on the final
day yes very exciting I'm looking
forward to that
so yes hopefully everyone is not sure
who my picks are cuz it's getting it's
if anything you're it
yeah everything is turned around well
thank you all very much for joining us
if you'd like to follow the games for
yourself see how this round concludes be
sure to do so at us chest champs calm
but other than that I think that's about
it from us today and we want to thank
our team that's Tony chin I wanted to
mention him first
I always forget about him then Simon and
Isaac's friends thank you so much for
having patience with us and especially
with me when I go over overtime but yeah
thank you so much guys and for watching
and we'll see you tomorrow be sure to
tune in tomorrow for our final coverage
of the winter chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you